the great thing about being here at
comic-con is the previews you get up
shows that are coming in the future and
in the spring of 2020 you will see
snowpiercer which is a crazy concept for
a new show explain snowpiercer
I'm gonna start with Jennifer kind of
explains ok well it's based on a graphic
novel and there's also a film called
snowpiercer so for fans of the film I
think you'll love the show as well
basically the show begins a little over
seven years after a catastrophic climate
event and the remains of humanity are
all on this train circling the globe
trying to write out this basically Ice
Age that we're we're in so it's a story
of the survivors trying to survive and
and find their way and the big deal is
with that with music with me yes because
also the train is separated into
different classes and everybody is
living in different classes so will
classroom you eight it's tough to tell
amongst us who's in the first yeah I
play Andre Layton who is is in the tail
which is the the lowest of classes on
the trance all the way in the back of
the Train projects of the Train the
projects but it's actually even its sub
projects these are people who didn't
have tickets at all and who forcibly
boarded the train in an effort to save
their lives at the end and sort of
through mercy of the engineer were
allowed to live in the last few cars on
the train in exchange for labor so they
live as long as they work Wow however
much like bunk beds that are yeah I mean
it's the last I'm worried about
bunk bed actually Pike's bed is pretty
pretty sweet you but it's crowded back
there so now from what I understand you
guys have already are starting to shoot
scenes
- right so what does that line will be
well we haven't started yet but we'll be
starting in that in the fall that's way
out in front isn't it yeah yeah is it
one of those things where you're like oh
we got to get it written first so give
me a minute but uh yeah we got the cut
seven great writers hard at work now
we've been at it for almost a couple
months and we'll start shooting in
October this year we've seen images
they're gonna give us any more than
images come on images only no sound it's
a silent groundbreaking
how is Comic Con been for you guys and I
know you've been here before you have
been here before I actually love coming
here and my husband is here today too so
it's sort of a family affair he's here
for some Avengers things and I love
coming here it's really fun kids are
here
first time have you walked the floor yet
not yet
what do you what do you think so far
which is my colleague and that poster is
insane
it's it's a yeah yeah first time first
time yeah this one I've been to the one
in New York it's crazy by the way to be
I want to help you out cuz I know you
are doing social media for another
channel now but it's okay you can go
ahead and pull out your phone I can take
a picture do your work okay all right
all right all right do you think like
yeah alright TBS insta story is good in
it we're gonna be going live pretty soon
on the TBS Instagram page probably if
they let me because they never shoulda
gave me the password
I don't want that et logo in the
background
one of the big deals here this week has
been the release of the Top Gun trailer
Jennifer what did you think
I think the trailer looks amazing I have
to say I for me every part of the
project has exceeded my expectations you
know watching the trailer being on the
set you know my experience of shooting
it's been phenomenal when you say that
people are already excited so now they
it really ramps up the excitement I am I
sign it all right it was great I was
excited to be part of it what they were
filming was extraordinary I'm excited to
see what how it comes together but I
it's what I saw was amazing
yeah you're musical guy gotta ask you
just one interesting question a lot of
buzz here and a lot of things that
people gonna talk about is this crazy
cats trailer have you seen it and your
thought oh wow oh yeah go ahead please
please go ahead going oh it going by
promising that has a much deeper
connection but it looks a joke I don't
you know Andy was our choreographer on
Hamilton so it's that the dancing looks
beautiful
obviously the music is stunning and they
there's dancing cats what's what's the
whole premise of that thing is pretty
you can't really sink it right I did the
show it was my first Broadway show I
ever did so I was actually in the show I
played demeanor which is the character
that Taylor Swift so I was like I was
like they're gonna do the movie because
they did one that was like it was
basically the show but they filmed it
which is like a 98 or something and so I
was wondering what it was gonna look
like and it's it is interesting yeah I
was like I couldn't like I was like what
am I looking at can't quite understand
it it takes a couple watches to really
understand what's going on as far as
what you're looking at with the CG right
physically the cats are very interesting
yeah yeah but the dancers look
and like it'll be fun to hear everybody
sing the music and and of course like
Jennifer Hudson's gonna sing they curve
it up remembering you know anything she
sings gonna be anybody I mean tell our
Smith's a swift can't hold a candle to
you come on Oh Taylor Swift where you at
Selena I heard I heard that your sets
are so crazy on this show and that often
you get lost and sometimes you end up in
a different class instead of the classic
supposed to be in because it's just it's
crazy how how are the saps I thought
this day I know less all the time
do you yeah I was people would find me
wandering around and this times like
they're good months into it I was still
getting lost which is kind of pathetic
of us no peers there's 1,001 cars long
and we only built like 982 thing that
threw me off so I was just gonna say is
I didn't think I don't I don't think we
were given the heads-up with the
movement of the train I know the first
day of shooting you got you're worried
you're all ready to add action and the
things started to do this and I just
went boy I got everything I forgot my
lines I didn't realize the motion of the
Train so that's all going on while there
while you're trying to shoot you're
getting the rocking the noise and grips
outside rocking the train up and down
every every time and they're just on
rubber wheels and the train cars move so
everybody's lurching at you're
constantly sort of am happy to walk
later this you know
on an airplane when you sort of hold up
top sort of threw me off it's just that
the great thing about the show is like
the beat said 1,001 cars long so you
never know what's gonna be in the next
car you go through a door and you can
find anything in that train car it's
what I like the beautiful things about
the movie that we've really brought to
the show so that's why we get lost
suddenly there's a new car
yes I was gonna say it's um you know to
that effect that it was so incredibly
rich the design of the Train in that
it's complexity I mean I think that you
know all of humanity is on this train
including not only all of humanity all
of animals that were left on the that
are being saved all the plants that are
being saved so you have all of these
ecosystems that are being preserved on
this train and so the diversity in the
cars and the different classes of the
cars and the way it's been realized is
so full and I thought really beautiful
so it's Noah's Ark on Rails right my
character rides a giraffe we see a
better person looks like what is a
uniform sitting up front
very officer like yeah she's I flamed
Melanie she's the head of hospitality so
I guess she was a uniform and I she's
very crisp and her job is she is in
charge of smooth relations on the train
and she is there to be the the voice of
mr. Wilford who is the engineer of the
train and to make sure that his Porter
has maintained
the hmm hospitality so that you know
Julie McCoy what comes to your mind when
you think of the hospitality the person
handling all the hospitality and helping
keep everything going straight now
meanwhile the rebo we see you great
coach looking rough and rugged and ready
to just go at somebody or like there was
some kind of confrontation happening in
that picture yeah yeah I don't know why
they didn't take any pictures of me from
the show that was just how I showed up
but it's ya know Layton is it's rough
times in the in the tale and Layton gets
gets the opportunity to come forward and
explore the rest of the train he's
pulled up to do a job and I think he's
constantly confronted with this this
linear class structure that ya remember
everybody in the tail hasn't seen
they've been stuck in these last cars
for seven years they haven't seen any of
the rest of this hasn't seen daylight
seven years so it's a there's some
interesting psychology going on with
with the class structure on this on this
train right they just sort of the not
imagine not seeing outside there are
seven years what does that do to a
person and then what does it do when
you're forced to all of a sudden work in
an environment where everybody gets that
where that is that is a right that you
have not been given and now you have to
help these people all right so when we
see a trailer today today yeah you will
drop the trailer today all right what
will we see in that trailer because
obviously this will air for us on the
kick Hopkins best trailer comic-con
coming out today
tell Tom Cruise grandmas in the lobby
Hotel the town comes theme
you